they are a symbol of a country in crisis
social movements representing millions
of people in need
on wednesday they marched to the center
of buenos aires and paralyzed
argentina's capital
pablo rojas works as a blacksmith he
says he makes around 50 dollars a month
and it's the only job he has been able
to find
i'm over 50 years old who's going to
give me a job we're like discarded
material nobody wants us that's why we
come here so the government does not
forget about us
there's entire families outside this
ministry in the center of buenos aires
poverty rates have been growing steadily
in the past years in argentina with an
exchange rate crisis and soaring
inflation that have had a huge impact on
people's purchasing power and that's why
most of the people here are saying that
they're going to stay at least for 48
hours until they get a response from the
government
[Music]
these protests happen as the government
announced the economy slowly recovering
poverty rates are dropping but inflation
continues to be the real challenge
last month it was close to 5 percent
march is expected to be even
monica higher is part of an organization
negotiating assistance for the poor
she says government programs don't do
enough to fight inflation
what we know is that every time
inflation goes up it sends a hundred
thousand people into poverty and we can
see that because salaries aren't high
enough to buy food all workers know this
[Music]
now president alberto fernandez is
trying to relaunch his economic agenda
argentina is like a big market what do
you need lithium we have it gas we have
it oil we have it food we have it so
let's get organized and take advantage
of the opportunities and let's
understand that everything the world
wants we can provide
argentina recently reached an agreement
with the international monetary fund to
restructure at least 45 billion dollars
in debt
the goal is to help stabilize the
country's economy but the war in ukraine
and rising commodity prices could
complicate the government plans
and that's why people here vow to keep
up with the pressure so the government
does not forget they are in desperate
need
perez